How Does Anti-Fog Spray Work?
The “fog” you may sometimes experience
on your glasses or goggles occurs when atmospheric
humidity near the lens condenses; this happens
due to a relatively significant discrepancy
between the temperature of the lens and the
surrounding air.
As the surface attempts to reach an equilibrium
between the two temperatures, heat energy
is given up; and, as the energy within the
gaseous water molecules decreases, they form
into tiny water droplets on your lens, otherwise
known as “fog.”
So how do we stop the fog from forming on
your glasses?
There are two primary types of substances
used here- surfactants and hydrophilic ingredients.
Surfactants (or surface acting agents) are
a broad group of compounds that include everything
from saliva to baby shampoo to emulsifiers.
(Incidentally, it is a surfactant that is
the reason certain things taste disgusting
after using toothpaste, see: Why Does Orange
Juice Taste Awful After Brushing Your Teeth.
Surfactants also play a key role in why dropping
a mentos in something like Diet Coke produces
such a strong geiser-like reaction.)
These work by lowering the surface tension
of water.
In the case of lens fog, which is essentially
just a bunch of tiny water droplets, the surfactant’s
ability to lower surface tension helps prevent
tiny droplet formation.
So instead of numerous tiny droplets forming
all over your glasses, you get a very thin
film of water that isn’t likely to interfere
with your vision.
If you don’t have an anti-fog spray handy,
in addition to human saliva and shampoo, other
soaps, glycerin and even, as previously mentioned,
certain substances in toothpaste, are surfactants
and thus will effectively prevent fog from
accumulating on a lens.
The other primary method for preventing fog
is to cover the lens with a hydrophilic coating,
which may include a polyvinyl alcohol, polymers,
hydrogels and colloids.
Meaning “water loving,” hydrophilic ingredients
absorb water and thus ultimately spread it
throughout the coating, similar to surfactants,
preventing the numerous tiny droplets
of
visible “fog.”